foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar a modern
approach to screening for monoclonal
gammopathies using digital workflows
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Sabia
to learn more please visit savia.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Dr Mark zaidman assistant professor of
pathology and Immunology at Washington
University School of Medicine St Louis
Missouri
Mark you may now begin your presentation
thank you so much for that kind
introduction
real pleasure to be here I'd like to
thank Sabia and labroots for the
invitation
today's talk a modern approach to
screening for monoclonal glamopathies
using digital workflows
combines two of my passions
part of my clinical role is
providing medical directors services for
monoclonal gammopathy diagnostics at
Barnes Jewish Hospital
my other role is that I serve as the
clinical faculty in this section of
clinical pathology informatics at
Washington University School of Medicine
so the application of computational
tools to improve laboratory efficiency
is a central role and theme in my work
I'd like to disclose that I've received
an honorarium for this talk as well as a
different talk related to multiple
myeloma testing
I also hold a patent for a method of
reducing interference in aminoassays
that can pertain to the serum free light
chain assay
the learning objectives today are to
discuss current evidence-based practices
for monoclonal gammopathy screening
to describe a paperless workflow for
integrating pathologist interpretation
into the testing workflow for monoclonal
gammopathies
and then to discuss the impact of this
paperless workflow on laboratory
operations at my Institution
provide some background monoclonal
gammopathies are diseases of abnormal
clonal plasma cell proliferation
these range from indolent entities such
as monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined
significance and smoldering multiple
myeloma which are best treated with
watchful weighting
to more aggressive entities such as
multiple myeloma and Al amyloidosis that
require prompts treatment usually with
multi-drug chemotherapy and bone marrow
transplantation
shown in this picture uh
this picture is illustrating that as
this disease process progresses an
important biomarker is the presence of
monoclonal proteins within the
peripheral circulation
and those will be the focus of this talk
today
I'd like to point out that
um there's a really happy story in this
field which is that outcomes have
improved dramatically for patients over
the past few decades
and this is thanks to the availability
of an increasing toolkit of treatments
for patients with monoclonal
chromopathies
the figure on the right shows data from
the National Cancer Institute
and illustrates that the five-year
relative survival for patients with
multiple myeloma relative to their
counterparts has improved from just
below 30 percent
as few as three decades ago
to nearly 60 percent
in the mid-2010s
now this increased survivorship also
means that there are increasing demands
on The Clinical Laboratory to provide
reliable information to identify
patients who will benefit from these
Therapies
monitor them for progression of their
disease
so for
um offerings from The Clinical
Laboratory the definitive study Remains
the bone marrow biopsy which provides
direct histology
definition
of plasma cells and characterization of
their clonality
however bone marrow biopsy is invasive
and expensive
and so we reserve this study for high
pre-test probability patients
as well as patients with a known
diagnosis at critical time points in
their treatment
outside of those specific use cases
the key Diagnostic and prognostic and
monitoring study Remains the detection
of M proteins or monoclonal proteins
in blood and urine specimen from the
patient
different guidelines released recently
from the College of American pathology
suggests the following algorithm for the
initial screening for monoclonal
commodities
this algorithm starts
with the clinicians
evaluation of their patient
if there is sufficient clinical
suspicion then they should order serum
protein electrophoresis s Pat
as well as serum free light chain assays
then if there's an abnormality on either
of these studies
reflex immunotyping and intact
immunocobulins should be performed
this panel is different from prior
panels that included a 24-hour urine
specimen
and it is also different from prior
panels that performs immunotyping up
front
so this panel offers a compromise
between
optimal sensitivity and the practicality
both to the patient and the laboratory
now one important caveat here is that
this this panel should not be applied to
Al amyloidosis upfront immunotyping is
still the recommended strategy
so I'm going to Pivot and tell you about
our practice at Barnes Jewish Hospital
and our experience with this new digital
workflow
first Barnes Jewish Hospital is located
in St Louis Missouri United States
it's a large adult Hospital housing
approximately 1300 beds
and this is a tertiary academic Care
Center associated with Washington
University School of Medicine
and working in close partnership with 14
other hospitals in the BJC healthcare
system
these hospitals reflect practice in both
community and academic tertiary care
setting practices
at Barnes Jewish Hospital or pjh we
offer a number of assays that help
detect and quantify monoclonal proteins
for serum studies we perform protein
electrophoresis
immunosubtraction electrophoresis and
immunofixation electrophoresis
as well as the serum free light chains
assay and quantitative intact
immunoglobulins
we have a narrower set of offerings for
urine studies including protein
electrophoresis and immunofixation
electrophoresis
we do not currently offer
immunosubtraction on urine although we
are currently partaking on a validation
study to bring up this analyte
to get a little more specific
um these are the assays and instruments
we utilize for protein electrophoresis
studies we are
mainly on the Serbia line of products
and we're doing our protein
electrophoresis using uh capillary
electrophoresis technology on the
capillars 3 instrument
and our preferred orderable for our
clinicians is called serum protein
electrophoresis s-pep with reflex
and this is uh pretty consistent with
the reflexive algorithm suggested by cap
so we perform up front
protein electrophoresis
and then immunotyping is performed if
the patient's sample is
hypogamma globulin anemic
this is a new patient and there's an
abnormality observed on the
electropherogram
if this is a known patient and we
observe a change in the pattern from a
previous study or if it's been at least
one year since the previous immunotyping
was performed
uh there's one more indication that I've
not listed here uh if the clinicians
order a separate Standalone immunotyping
we will of course honor that request
now the decision to perform immunotyping
by immunofixation versus
immunosubtraction
is driven by the pattern on s-pep
as well as the pathologist's comfort
with these two different immunotyping
assays
we find that most Pathologists presented
with a clear abnormal Peak will prefer
immunosubtraction for the operational
efficiency to the lab
but there is variation uh some
Pathologists have adopted this newer
assay While others remain more
comfortable with immunopixation
looking at our order volumes for 2022
we are a high volume testing center
we received approximately 17.5
thousand orders
for these tests in 2022 most of these
are coming from the outpatient setting
um with a much smaller set coming from
in patients
predominantly clinicians are utilizing
our preferred order which is the s-pep
with reflex versus the Standalone s-pep
and immunotyping orders
One Challenge we face is that our order
volumes fluctuate dramatically from day
to day and this is really driven by the
fact that we have a large myeloma Clinic
that sees patients twice a week
so here I'm just plotting the volume per
day for a couple weeks in November of
and what you can see is that on the
weekends we might get three or nine
orders while on those myeloma Clinic
days we can receive well over 100 orders
to process
and it can be very challenging to keep
up with that level of volume
associated with that fluctuation in
volume there's also fluctuation in the
indication for testing obviously our
uh myeloma Clinic days we're seeing
primarily patients with a known
diagnosis of myeloma or another
monoclonal commopathy and those are you
know the greatest fraction of our orders
on other days we might see orders from
neurology working at polyneuropathy or
from endocrine working up bone disease
or hypercalcemia
now it's not reflected in the figure I'm
presenting which is based on order
Associated ICD-10 codes
that only come with outpatient
where we're missing the inpatient
testing indications anecdotally I'll
share those tend to be unexplained renal
impairment as well as patients with a
noted elevated protein Gap
this is all quite relevant information
to the pathologist because the pre-test
probability of detecting a monoclonal
protein is going to be very different on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and Friday
and Pathologists often have that
pre-test probability in their minds when
they're trying to interpret subtle
defects within a protein electrophoresis
study
so this brings us to a problem we had we
really wanted to reevaluate how we could
increase the efficiency of our workflow
process
so that we could accommodate these very
high testing volumes that were growing
year over year
what we came up with was that we could
improve our efficiency by transitioning
away from a legacy paper driven workflow
to a new uh digital based workflow
this transition occurred in January of
2022.
so on the left I'm showing you our
previous workflow
so what would happen is the technologist
would run the study
they would then template an
interpretation of those studies
they would print the study as well as
the most recent prior study and they
would actually print on two different
colors of paper so that it was obvious
which was the current and which was the
prior
they would then go to a very large file
cabinet and retrieve physical note cards
on which was written all the historical
results for protein electrophoresis and
immunofixation for our known patients
and these note cards would serve as a
companion to the pathologist so that
they didn't have to spend time digging
into patient charts one by one to see
the historical results
at this point the pathologist would come
in sit at the bench with these stacks of
papers
and they would annotate the physical
sheets so if they were in agreement with
the interpretation they could sign those
uh providing their attestation
if they were in disagreement they could
correct the physical copy as well as
request add-on or reflexive testing
next the technologist would have to
manually transcribe all these results
from the paper copy into our laboratory
information system
they would also have to manually update
these physical history cards with the
new results
and then file them back into their
correct location in the file cabinet
now the work new workflow looks much
simpler
the technologist runs the study
and templates the interpretation
and then the pathologist
will sign and validate that
interpretation or change it or request
add-on testing right within the software
environment
once the study is validated it flows
through a digital environment and
automatically to our laboratory
information system and next to the
electronic health record to land in the
patient chart
so comparing these two workflows you can
see we now have fewer steps
and we have eliminated all physical
intermediate paper
trail that was part of the workflow on
the left
so our motivation was to simplify the
workflow to improve efficiency
we also wanted to be able to bring the
relevant data to the pathologist so they
could still be informed when they're
interpreting the studies
we wanted to decrease transcriptional
errors that are known to be associated
with manual transcription steps in the
laboratory
we want to reduce our waste Trail
and as we went through uh covid
and the unpredictability of Staffing we
wanted to be able to enable remote
productivity to disaster proof ourselves
in a way
so the strategy was to migrate the
pathologist review process
from the physical world into the phrasis
software
paresis is the software developed by
Sabia that triggers the instrument and
collects the data
all right so the major challenge here
looking back
was that
while the technologists workflow has
become much simpler since they don't
have to do all these transcriptional
steps the pathologist workflow has
become a bit more complicated
previously the pathologist would simply
sign a piece of paper and move on now
they had to learn a digital workflow
involving various modules within the
freezes software
and I'll just highlight up front this is
probably the major limitation of our new
workflow is that we're using a software
that was not designed for the
Pathologists
interpretation it was designed for data
acquisition and therefore the
organization of the software is centered
around these different modules
corresponding to the different assays
uh this was not you know insurmountable
we just had to explain to the
pathologist how to navigate through the
different modules to interpret the
various studies
so on the right this schematic outlines
the pathologist navigation there's a
startup process they then interpret the
same protein electrophoresis studies
this is the main activity of their day
they'll then view urine protein
electrophoresis
validate immunofixations
and then validate any immunosubtractions
so the s-pep workflow this is again
most of the time that pathologist spends
and so I'll just outline quickly this
process and then the subsequent ones
will be pretty similar
so this starts with the pathologist
opening the module Within pharysis
loading a work list
and opening a patient study
they are able to review the fraction
gating and adjust it if necessary
and then really the uh one of the
aspects we love about this process is
that they're able to access and directly
compare the current electropherogram
with all historical results with the
direct overlay
I think that's a real benefit uh to the
interpretation of those studies
and we can do that without having to go
to a file cabinet of printed historical
studies and dig through to find a prior
next the pathologist can review any
abnormal Peak annotations and gating
and then they can review any reflexive
testing that was produced
again at our institution we perform both
immune subtraction and immunofixation so
depending on which study was performed
and one click the pathologist can open
up and view that study
and they can add their interpretation
and their signature
now there's a little difference here for
immunosubtraction they're able to
validate right within this workflow
but due to limitations of the software
immunofixation cannot be validated
within the s-pep workflow and has to be
validated in a subsequent workflow
schema
uh after reviewing these Associated
studies the Pathologists can either
request additional testing which we
accomplish through a note to the
technologist within the interpretive
comments
or they can go ahead add their digital
signature and validate the study
uh one additional problem we've run into
here is that the immunofixation images
these are scanned images of physical
gels have to be manually attached and so
we just had to reinforce with the
technologist how important it was that
they reliably attached those images that
we would have them associated with the
studies both for the interpretation
today as well as if we need to look back
in the future
all right so I went to that first
workflow in details so the others will
move more quickly
the urine protein electrophoresis
workflow looks almost identical with the
exception that we do not have
immunosubtraction
offered at our institution so all
reflexive immunotyping is done via
immunofixation
uh next the pathologist needs to go into
a separate workflow opening a different
program in order to validate the
immunofixation studies
as well as review any Standalone cases
we do event we do occasionally receive
requests for isolated immuno typing
studies typically coming from neurology
this is a pretty quick process one
limitation here in the other workflows
we were able to implement a validation
hotkey which is a nice uh
productivity solution so you don't have
to click you can just hit a single
keystroke and that's not available
within this particular module of paresis
the it validation workflow is similar to
that for immunofixation you can review
the Standalone cases and validate those
Amino subtractions that have not already
been validated in the s-pep process
so that's a lot of detail let me zoom
out
the pros and cons of our new digital
workflow
there's a lot to like we have
dramatically decreased the
transcriptional work burden on the
technician
and as Laboratories continue to be
squeezed for staff I think this is the
primary value the real core value of
this transition
theoretically we've reduced
opportunities for transcriptional errors
this is hard to quantify as those
transcriptional errors were difficult to
detect in the Legacy process
we have certainly reduced paper
consumption
all the Pathologists have been quite the
fans of the ability to directly compare
the current study to historical studies
going all the way back through the
history of the patient
this really helps to know if
there's a change in the electropherogram
if that's consistent with the patient's
known monoclonal proteins migration
pattern
there are a couple unanticipated
benefits
um because we're working this digital
environment
it's quite easy to take a screenshot of
the study to share with clinicians when
they have questions about how we're
interpreting a study or a change that
occurred in their patients results
and it really helps them to be able to
see what we're seeing to better
understand why we're coming to the
interpretation that we provided
similarly when we have a very
challenging study
we can take a screenshot and consult our
colleagues and have other Pathologists
weigh in on it
before this digital transition we either
had to take a picture and scan that
picture and then share it or we had to
take the physical copy and walk over to
our colleague's office so now we have
almost real-time feedback hey what do
you think of this study
and then another unanticipated benefit
was we were able to set up some very
efficient data capture mechanisms in
order to facilitate our part B billing
for interpretations and I'll talk about
this a little more in a in a following
slide
it's not what have been the challenges
uh there was a lot of build here we
needed new Lis interfaces between
foresis and our laboratory information
system
um
that we did not have because we did not
need them for a paper process
there still are many clicks and many
modules for the pathologist
um this certainly slowed us down
compared to the prior process at least
from the pathologist perspective but
this uh
everyone's become a lot more efficient
with a little bit of training so this
issue has lessened over time
there is a learning curve and uh you
know the onboarding process takes a
little more time for Pathologists
and then there are just a couple you
know wish list items the user interface
varies across these different modules it
would be great if there was a consistent
location of the different buttons
and then we did run into an intermittent
has been subsequently addressed by the
savior's support
so our data capture for Part B billing
so
before January 1st 2022 we were not
billing for our interpretations and that
was for a couple reasons one was
um we didn't have enough MD Pathologists
to sign out our cases
which has since changed
and then second
um
we just didn't have the resources to
print sign and scan studies simply for
the documentation of our signature
and so we were able to integrate the
capture of the pathologist's attestation
and have that transmit across the
interface from faresis to our Las and
then from the Las to our EHR billing
module
and so now we do uh
we are able to bill for an
interpretation which has been a sizable
new Revenue stream about 350 000 US
dollars in 2022 alone
and hopefully will continue to be you
know that reliable Revenue stream
all right last I'd like to highlight a
couple of solutions that we've developed
for further workflow optimization within
this digital work workflow
so first of all um
I have to say a big thank you to Damien
Marquez who's provided great support as
we undertook this transition
and really helped us to configure For
Recess to make our work more efficient
for example he helped us set up an
automatic communication to the Lis so
there's no manual clicking up transmit
he helped us make sure that our
interpretive comments stay synced across
modules so if we're viewing
an attached immunofixation in the aspect
workflow and change the interpretation
when we log into the other module where
we can validate immunofixation those
changes are consistent and persist and
this was really important to you know
prevent confusion and to synchrony
between those interpretations
he helped us configure our database such
that we could be in charge of our own
user credentials uh even prior to that
reconfiguration we couldn't accomplish
that because we were sharing a database
with a sister Hospital
and that allowed us to provide you
credentials in order to be compliant
with requirements in the laboratory
and he also layered atop some quick key
productivity tools so that we could move
more efficiently through our through our
interpretive process
I have developed a software package that
takes these physical history note cards
and automates the generation and
updating and maintenance of those note
cards so what I'm showing in this
picture on the right this was the file
cabinet that the technologists needed to
visit each day
and retrieve up to let's say 80
different
patient cards from their location
and then file them back at the end of
the day this was a very laborious step
what I did is I developed a python
package that runs on a scheduled job
that will retrieve all this information
from our laboratory database create a
nicely formatted report and drop it in a
shared folder that the pathologist can
access and have a second screen as
they're working within pharysis so over
here you have varesis with current study
and on the next screen is this report
which allows you to
historical results without having to
visit the patient charts
so the elements that are in this report
include some patient demographics
ordering provider information and all
these historical results as we look to
Future upgrades this tool we will
integrate serum free light chain results
order Associated ICD-10 codes
as well as information
to tell the pathologist if the patient
has received ertumumab within the prior
six months and this will help as their
two and mab of course can interfere with
protein electrophoresis testing
um we had a very talented uh medical
student rotate with us who generated a
little Auto hotkey software allowing us
to program our interpretive comment
dictionaries and create little quick
tests
that's what's being demonstrated in the
video on the right this was a great
solution to standardized data entry
across varesis modules
and is compatible with our Citrix
application instance and easily
reconfigurable
for all these software Solutions I'm
happy to share source code to anyone
who's interested and you can just email
me at the indicated email below
so concluding thoughts we have
successfully transitioned from a largely
paper-based to an entirely digital
workflow
I haven't shown the data but our
turnaround times have remained stable
through this transition
this is not entirely surprising uh the
key bottleneck for our turnaround time
is the fact that the technologists
typically works in the morning and the
pathologist is not usually available
until the end of day to enter their
interpretations
uh we are
currently collecting data to compare
error rates pre and post but do not have
a long enough observation period uh post
stabilization as we've been continuing
to optimize our strategy
wish list for improving this process if
any brilliant programmers at Sabia want
to think about this for the next version
of paresis
I would love to see a separate
pathologist and technologist Q such that
a case can be assigned to one or the
other
this would really help to stay organized
as we collaborate to complete this
testing
it would also be great if there was a
concept of a case instead of an assay
what do I mean by that so take our
example from surgical pathology where a
specimen can be accessioned under one
accession number and then subjected to
all the necessary testing to assign a
diagnosis so in this way the protein
electrophoresis the immunotyping free
light chains could all fall under one
concept
that could be interpreted and validated
together
with that I would like to conclude by
acknowledging various Folks at Barnes
Jewish Hospital thanks to Natalia ozipov
and Jennifer Hayes who are managers of
this section of our laboratory thanks to
all the technologists on the bench who
had to deal with you know dramatic
changes to their workflows
thanks to the I.T support from James
Hugh and the interface and building
teams
thanks to our washu Pathologists who
again have learned a new workflow
and then thanks again to Sabia
especially Damian Marquez who has worked
with us happy to step through this
transition
and thanks as well to Tammy close
with that I'm happy to take any
questions and I look forward to further
discussion
thank you Mark for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
asks what impact did the new
computer-based workflow have on
turnaround times
uh thank you Kaylee um
yeah as we mentioned so the turnaround
times have largely remained stable
for some patients we are processing
those samples faster uh for there are a
couple that stand a little longer but
ultimately when we analyze our workflow
we think that the limitation on
turnaround time is more related to the
handoff between the technologist and the
pathologist and the constraints on their
scheduling rather than you know the
actual time it takes to complete the
work
great thank you another question we have
here how is clinical information
accessed at the time of interpretation
yeah great question
um so we've tried to facilitate the
pathologist by bringing the
um information they need to interpret
those studies into one centralized
report and that's those digital s-pep
cards
so primarily the pathologist is going to
access information within pharysis where
they'll be able to look at all the prior
studies and do direct overlays of those
studies
uh as well as this Excel spreadsheet
report which is going to provide the
numeric value for all the prior s-pap
immunofixation and urine studies
unfortunately we still do have to open
up patient charts at least several times
a day if we have deeper questions
regarding the clinical context
of the study as well as
treatments such as deratumumab or other
monoclonal therapies that might be
relevant to our interpretation of the
study
so uh to summarize in parisis in our
Associated report as well as in our EHR
great thank you I have another question
here for you and this one asks What
proportion of your immunotyping is
performed by capillary immunosubtraction
versus immunofixation and how do these
results compare and why maintain both
Technologies
um yes great questions thank you for
those
um so we really try to prioritize and
you know subtraction because it is
operationally much more efficient to
perform
we I would say probably do two immuno
subtractions to every one immunofixation
we keep both studies for several reasons
um
one is that we use both so the
utilization schema is based on the
pathologist's preference comfort and
interpretation of the current study
and we do find uh frequent cases where
an immunosubtraction was performed but
there's still ambiguity and so the
pathologist chooses to perform
immunofixation as well
uh there are concerns related to uh the
sensitivity
of the immunosubtraction emerging data
has shown that you know real experts in
this assay can achieve similar
sensitivity as immunofixation
I'm not sure if we yet consider
ourselves to be true Experts of
immunosubtraction
but anecdotally there are cases where
it's really nice to have both side by
side
there are instances where the
immunosubtraction is more interpretable
than the immunofixation as well as vice
versa
and then finally I'll add that some of
our patients are on clinical trials
protocols that have specifically asked
for immunopixation so we do keep the uh
assay around for utilization in those
cases as well
great we're getting some great questions
in from our audience here so we're going
to proceed this next question asks do
you include any benign changes in the
interpretation such as acute
inflammation pattern beta gamma bridging
Etc
um you know uh we don't typically
that's not entirely true uh we don't
typically comment on uh consistent with
acute inflammation pattern beta gamma
bridging
um we will note this album anemia for a
couple patients that have that benign
finding uh but I think we tend to be
um simple as best with our
interpretations focusing on the presence
or absence of a restricted Peak
great
this question here asks do your
Pathologists still look at gels or
entirely look at scans and chromatograms
what are your thoughts about complete
telepathology for protein assessment
hmm
yeah
so uh we do still look at gels
one limitation this brings up which
should be mentioned these scanned images
are
um not of the resolution that I would be
comfortable interpreting for primary
diagnosis
um so I would say it would be great to
achieve a future state where a complete
telepathology is possible uh but I would
for sure want to
um you know have the validation study to
say that we're performing equivalently
looking at physical gels versus uh
scanned images
um I will say that um
looking to that future one unintended
negative consequence would be less
communication between the pathologist
and the technologist there's kind of an
organic exchange that happens when the
pathologist walks into the lab uh to the
bench and says Hi how are you doing uh
how did everything go today were there
any problems
so I am a little bit leery that we're
going to lose that interaction that
occurs in the physical space but I think
having the ability to perform
telepathology uh may be
um
a great Tool uh both for unexpected
issues like covid as well as the ability
to uh you know bring the expert
pathologist Services into places that
don't have the resources to run their
own run and interpret their own studies
great
next question here asks are the
Pathologists able to lock in to the same
instance of pharysis for interpretations
while the technicians may be working on
something else
uh yes so uh yes and no so they're both
able to work simultaneously we actually
have a separate instance that's on our
Citrix
uh that the Pathologists can access from
any computer on our intranet or um with
a virtual private network connection to
our Intranet then the technologists
typically work on the bench which has a
local instance of foresis installed so
there's no locking each other out of the
application
now we do try to discourage working at
the same time on the same studies
because there's the opportunity to get
confused
where the pathologist and technologists
are changing the same interpretation at
the same time and this is where a data
concept of a pathologist work queue and
a technologist work you could help us to
stay organized by assigning that study
to one or the other
eight
next question here which Lis do you have
we enter interpretations in Epic beaker
we are using Cerner millennium
and our EHR is epic
great
next question do the technologists or
the Pathologists perform the
interpretations
uh yes both do so the technologists
template the interpretation
and then the pathologist reads behind
and either
um
signs if they agree or modifies the
interpretation and then signs
uh this is I think a great solution for
a couple reasons one is that I think
it's very engaging to the technologists
to be involved in that way and to get to
interpret and work through the study
but two is that it's also very useful
having two eyes on the study does indeed
catch uh you know errors
data entry errors and so we continue to
have both technologists and Pathologists
participating in the interpretation
process
great thank you this next question
um is a bit of a two-part question so it
is a little bit longer
um this question asks what is the
workflow related to the Lis interface
for example is the spep numerical data
from the capillaries entered and
verified separately by the technologists
and then the pathologist's
interpretation from phoresis is
interface we use speaker and have the
capillaries interfaced but the intrap is
currently manually entered by the
pathologist into Beaker each has
separate outstanding lists
so uh the workflow is that when the
interpretation is complete the
pathologist clicks the validation button
and then after a at regular time
intervals there will be an automatic
communication that captures both the
numeric values and the interpretive
comments and communicates them across an
interface from phoresis to our Las which
is Cerner
and then in Cerner uh we have discrete
data elements uh corresponding to the
fraction quantifications uh restricted
Peak gating as well as the interpretive
comment so these are an automatic flow
there is an option then to hold up the
results within our Lis for manual review
and verification or if one feels
comfortable to turn on an auto
verification whereby those results will
automatically flow from our Lis to the
electronic health record
great thank you this next question is
also a three-part question do you have a
limit below which you do not provide a
concentration of a deductible serum band
if so what is the cut off and what do
you tell clinicians if there is a
visible band but the area under the
curve is zero
[Music]
question
we don't have a hard cut off we use the
Pathologists uh you know Acumen and part
of that reason is that sometimes you
could have a sizeable peak but because
it's co-migrating for example with
normal proteins within a beta band it is
obvious that it would be grossly
overestimated if we did our typical
gating schema
uh we do place a comment uh that says
quantity too low to quantify
uh if there's obviously an a small
abnormal Peak that we don't think we can
accurately quantify
um our clinicians are pretty uh well
versed in the use of alternative
quantification schemes for
bands that are migrating in the beta
region for example
great thank you next question here do
you continue to perform immunofixation
each time you get a patient with an
immunoglobulin that is considered too
small to quantitate
the answer is it depends
so certainly
um so a patient with a immunocobulin too
small so absolutely if it's the first
time we see that patient
um
and then there's a little bit of
practice variation I will admit between
pathologists
um
I think probably if you see the abnormal
Peak at least let me say in my practice
if I see an abnormal Peak and it's a
known abnormal Peak and we know the
immunotype I don't think there's much
value to repeating that immunofixation
now if that if that Peak then on a
subsequent study goes away I think it's
very relevant to uh test with the
immunofixation to be able to communicate
to the clinician if uh there's still
biochemical evidence of uh that M
protein
I think emerging Technologies uh that
get at deeper mrd testing minimal
residual disease testing might make
these questions a little bit more moot
in the future
great
another question we have here does your
facility perform immunofixation when the
Kappa Lambda ratio is elevated but the
spep
electrophoretogram shows no obvious
abnormalities
yes we do that was that was not shown on
the algorithm but yes we do that's an
alternative Pathway to immunofixation
great thank you
all right
next question here is the part that's
signing by the pathologist required for
a result interpretation
I'm sorry can you repeat that question
please Kaylee yes is the part that's
signing by the Pathologists required for
result interpretation
uh it's not required in that we don't
have
uh you know a hard stop logic that will
prevent you from validating without your
signature I wish we did because
typically you'll get an email from the
billing department that your signature
is missing and we'll have to go back in
and correct so I wish we did have a hard
stop because it would help us catch if
we ever missed our attestation but it's
not required at this point
great once an interpretation is
validated in For Recess could you be
able to modify it
uh yes you can
you can unvalidate
and change your interpretation
uh one caveat there is that if that
result has already been communicated to
the laboratory information system uh
then it is necessary to
um
to then manually uh issue a correction
into the information system and to the
patient chart
which we have uh implemented just via a
manual uh process outlined in an sop
great
well we're going to go ahead and wrap up
there today Mark did you have any final
comments for our audience today
uh I just want to say thank you to
everyone for your attention and for your
thoughtful questions
um thank you to Sabia for the support in
this transition and the invitation
um you know this has been an interesting
uh project to work on and I think it
represents kind of a creative solution
to dealing with the pressures that all
Laboratories are feeling right now which
is how are we going to look to a future
where we can be more efficient with
fewer uh ftes
um and then the last thing I'll say is
again if anyone wants to discuss this
process or our experience or would like
source code for some of the tools we
developed please reach out by email and
I'd be happy to follow up
great well thank you again Mark for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Sabia for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
so until next time take care everyone
goodbye